liu le monde sait ce musicien se
retrouvent pour la suite de the cost of
bref on prenait donc ce petit chemin qui
nous menait vers probablement un endroit
plus glauque que les autres il aime bien
non je veux faire que des endroits
glauques c'est magnifique il ya que du
glauque du glauque duo je vois de la
lumière j'aime la lumière et la main en
or elle le possède
c'est au plus tard je n'aime pas trop ça
pauvre insectes attendant mais c'est
quoi cet entrepôt vega shoah
non non bon c'est bon j'ai bâton de
streamer de la cape à ça ça je crois que
ça veut dire combien on peut pas aller
là bas
d'accord d'accord j'ai compris à votre
avis c'est tout droit où on emprunte la
non tout droit valait ouais c'était bien
j'aime bien moi tout droit aux hommages
et sauté j'ai eu le réflexe à temps mais
en vrai si je tombais qui se passe est
absolument rien aux à tort la maison et
car mon style et là c'est pas la petite
cabane du début à h&m pas trop ce sera
déjà privé du bruit sql fantômes qui en
train de faire des steaks banon de bien
aux rituels 2 yallop aux [ __ ] j'avais
porté sur une chanson même à stopper ne
s'est pas du tout passé comme prévu a vu
que je peux pas crier parce que j'ai les
cordes vocales qui ne sont pas du tout
en meilleur état canard foie
je suis obligé de d'exprimer ma peur
dans les gestes
pourquoi déjeuner dans une région elle
est là pourquoi dès que je traverse une
route aller là où alex patrick ollier là
en fait ben cousins va emprunter la voie
voilà alors aulas va se faire condamner
par contre je crois bien gauche ou
droite
anna may yan tu vas me faire peur encore
je voulais chanter elle va me faire peur
salut bon bah tu avais trouvé l'osm
était mort bah oui bon il me revient de
droit très bien merci pour l'os et puis
bon voyage il est temps d'emprunter un
autre chemin
jma qui va se passer sur le retour
exemple qui a pas un seul qui va glisser
vers nous cette fois la droite à
non mais ça ça mais nulle part enfin ça
mais nous décès quoi mais rien là dedans
c'est sûr tu sur sa maison de l'ombre
démoniaque
waouh ça ça tombe ça tourne ça tourne ça
tombe je ressors je ressors je reviens
steinbach steinbach je reviens bien plus
tôt voilà qui a été caché dans les bouts
de bois tout va bien je ne devrais pas
marcher dans le tunnel
merci pour le conseil un peu trop tard
oui donc je peux pas y aller mais là bas
rien d il ya un truc
voilà c'était la négation du jour
puisque je pas le prendre en tant que
casque pour me protéger de cette [ __ ]
de moi mais le sur ta tête bordel donc
là c'est la hoya leçon on va aller par
là je sens qu'il va nous arriver des
choses fantastiques voit par exemple se
faire décapiter dans cette cabane
à une autre maison à l'est beaucoup
moins stylé que l'autre est ce que
quelqu'un a confiance dans cette maison
absolument personne un objet ya un truc
qui te prends tu te barres sans problème
sans problème en recul ou combien je
savais qu'il y avait un truc pas du tout
bête avec cette [ __ ] de maison ont
déjà premièrement ils sont ils sont tous
voisins là pourquoi ils s'entraident pas
ce qu'ils sont tous décédés se nommait
nous cette histoire dans la brume très
bien c'est parfait pour se faire
décapiter sont jamais être retrouvées
ça me plaît bien alors je moi j'aime
bien spectre déjà les endroits pour y
voilà par exemple les toilettes or les
petits détails
voilà aussi examiner les bûches pas vrai
on va tout examiné de sorte à retarder
le moment va devoir lancer [ __ ] de
maison puisque je peux pas arrêter bien
le courant avant eh ben on y va voilà
hoya veille avait le monstre r la
fenêtre enfin je crois que j'ai
peut-être des destinations ceop la
petite pierre pour moi canapés ont
plutôt mauvaise et a à revendre de toute
urgence
ainsi le screamer 1 mais regardez quoi
il ses longs bras et tout non les
paroles se cacher sous la table
bon je prévois pour évasion ok laissez
moi tranquille je sais que suis tout à
fait ridicule si je fais semblant de
dormir
non on se cache au coi à des murs comme
ça oui tu as des couilles au [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] ça a marché qu'est ce qu'a
fait qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle tape au
plafond et à promouvoir tout elles vont
construire la maison alors je suis
dedans tu ne m'auras pas cher c'est un
piège
je n'irai pas là-bas bon inquiète façon
c'est ça ou je décède ici alors autant y
aller c'est bon oh non mais elle est
bien trop lourde là et voilà à mon cas
[ __ ] vos toilettes pour fêter ça y est
mais qu'est-ce qui m'a tuer c'est laid
c'est long comme ça qu'ils rentraient
dans moi ça c'est fait bon et rien
derrière je fais comme toi je te regarde
dedans c'est leur bord un accès des
remords l intrigue cours supermeet
regardez là haut non non non je dis ça y
est ralenti il avait une montée
d'adrénaline on pouvait plus web quelque
part un patin s'est ouvert je sais où il
est bon on va prendre ce chemin là oh
oui
qu'est ce que c'était que ça moi aussi
c'est le faire
pas donc à ce qu'est ce qui lui a appris
à faire le crabe le barça à mon avis
c'est pour aller à faire le truc finale
du coup faut retourner au portail de
l'autre côté au oui c'est bien là le tra
la voir la lumière qui s'est éteinte
j'espère que c'est ce passage accès
ouvert c'est non vraiment je je fais
rien en fait yes
alors ça faut que je prenne tout ça ça
suffit gran à olhao oui j'ai cru je
m'envolais [ __ ] hameau ne peut tuer
pas madame merci ldp elle est là si je
passe je meurs faut trouver un autre
chemin par la non nous sommes trop gros
par la halle et à emmerdes
allez je te laisse là tranquillement à
imiter les flaques d'eau 1 en wav attend
au nord au maine
par là il ya une échelle c'est bien
michel ça une échelle pour les enfants
voilà pour les 4 6 ans voilà up
olalalala allez je te laisse imiter les
flag no 1
cordialement le chemin à travers le pont
et toof c'est ouvert
yes ça sent le rituel ça sent le bon
petit rituel que j'aime bien oui je me
suis senti obligé de le montrer mes
fesses et partir en courant je suis
désolé mais la couenne me court après
comme ça vraiment ça me fout ça m'a
vraiment ça me au pardon c'est une
blague
qu'est ce qui m'a fait là elle m'a mis
un petit coup comme ça sur la cheville
laisse-moi fait la vidéo la célèbre
faire ça son approche bizarre non c'est
bon tu peux te casser je m'en bats les c
est à nous finalement non finalement je
t'aime la vingtaine d'ag remets toi hein
mais non mais je suis content moi je dis
ça mais en vrai comment je reviens en
arrière je suis condamné à rester avec
l'ombre démoniaque je découvre un nouvel
endroit qui ressemble fortement à tous
les autres endroits étant donné que les
bouts de bois et des feuilles à ça va se
passer là bas
bon ça se passe c'est des tribunes pour
vous alors insérer les eaux voilà stone
bim up stone up stone stone pour changer
la dernière j'ai journée je n'ai pas
cinq non il peut pas mettre son bras
comme ça dans perpendiculaire et du
rouge
il ya du rouge y'a du y est ce la
cinquième pierre je ne peux plus trop
bouger oui et la colère ou la colère de
la mort brutale bloque pas quoi c'est
pas un petit plat n'est pas un
psychiatre que ton père côté petit dans
l'ansé bon y est
c'est bon ça ça a l'air gentil est
innocent elle s'envole voilà au revoir
oh [ __ ] s'envole bien vite quoi
d'accord il ya une tempête il faut que
je me barre vite d'ici c'est ce qui est
indiqué promis je me barre vite dit si
ça ne m'arrêtera pas aller à l'aider sur
les marches vite sont même saute sauvage
aux halles et la barque et là on voit
l'ombre qui se barre sur la barque
tranquillement aux plages sur la barque
ok d'accord du prophète l'histoire c'est
que le mec qui avait un accident de
voiture donc ensuite il devait être un
peu dans le coma ou quoi il était à dans
cette fameuse forêt accosté chapelet en
bas qui s'est réveillé il était dans sa
voiture etc
et il y avait une ambulance et c'est
aujourd'hui pour lui porter secours il a
vu une femme au loin avec un visage à
moitié transparent sourire et lui dire
merci
voilà c'est tout pour moi et sur ce je
vais postuler en tant que prof d'anglais
dans l'école des tapis temps bombe en
région c'est la fin de cette deuxième et
dernière vidéo sur le sol corse est
souvent vrai tu sais ça vous plaît qu'on
finisse ensemble un jeu comme ça en
vidéo n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo en
plus ça fera un grand plaisir à tout le
monde a pis tu vas où outtara t on mais
la torre tard